our friend from the tampa bay times back
here on the rich eisen show rick stroud
joining us here
what's up rick strout how are you
hey rich i'm doing well i'll bet you
don't have a norm boulash autograph i
think that was the first one i remember
150 years ago that's your first
autograph you collected
as like as like a an infant
like somebody brought it home i was like
back in the day
you know yeah i think honestly one of
the first autographs i ever got was neil
simon's the playwright because he we ran
into him outside of a theater once and i
knew who he was because i was a die-hard
odd couple fan even at age like eight
you know
yeah so
it's amazing i'm into sports because my
dad was only into like broadway musicals
and things like that it's truly a
a miracle what i do for a living to be
very honest with you but anyway thanks
for calling rick
um let's get into it boy did you piss
people off by saying blaine gabbard's
the number one option at quarterback for
the bucks i saw a lot of the reaction to
your reporting on twitter
i tend to get that reaction no matter
what i say rich i you know it's just i
don't know this twitter twitter universe
is a is a mean place but
actually i didn't say it um
said it to me you know this is the thing
like so uh i told this i was going for a
bike ride first one since august i think
and um i had asked bruce about something
coaching or something like that earlier
you know he just
this this latest story you know that
came out or this
text or tweet or whatever it was on
social media about
you know him and tom um sort of having a
bad relationship or things going sour or
however it was phrased really got to him
you know
and you know we talked about that and we
and we you know we started talking about
quarterbacks but i mean
i i think it's pretty clear you know
there's this
a lot of this is fantasy football right
and we can run down the list but where
they stand right now at quarterback
is the only guy on the roster is kyle
trask who they like but he's never
played he had a redshirt year didn't get
a helmet one day out of the 17 regular
season games to postseason
and they're probably going to resign
blaine um for some incentive later
contract
they like blaine gabbard but you know
run through the list russell wilson
really is he going to be traded from the
seattle seahawks is that going to happen
okay three number one picks these guys
picked 27th i i don't think he's going
to be traded because i don't think pete
carroll at 70
wants to start over
um at quarterback unless russ just
really wants out of there and so they'll
they'll check into that aaron rodgers no
he's not going to be traded to an nfc
team i don't think
if he leaves at all so the two guys we
know that are going to be traded jimmy
garoppolo
they don't like them you know if you ran
the ball 40 times sure but that's not
what they do here they they throw the
ball down the field that's not garoppolo
strength or he would have won a super
bowl by now
and then you have deshaun watson and you
know from what my information is at
least certainly as it stands today
the glazer family is on the bus they're
just not going to sign off on that one
you know there's a i always say this
have the press conference right
what does that look like um and so you
know maybe that situation changed maybe
he clears that up i don't know but you
look at the rest of it
carson wentz they don't think he's an
upgrade
more than likely more than likely
i think this team will probably end up
with blaine back there and then bring in
one of the second tier type guys and i
don't know if it'll be him but maybe a
teddy bridgewater who will have to
compete
and then continue to develop
you know their young quarterback and
kyle trask i mean
if any of this other stuff happens and
and you know look philadelphia i guess
could convince seattle to get rid of
russell wilson and then all of a sudden
maybe you know
there's another quarterback on the
market that's young and attractive to
them i don't know but i just think
i just think that they really
would get by okay with blaine who's been
in this system you know now
since arizona and
he's not going to excite anybody but
you know that's just where it stands
right now it's it's not fantasy football
it's it's reality
so i got a name for you rick stroud let
me bounce this one off you it's a wild
card wild name but he is available what
about jameis winston coming back what
about that one yeah you know i i've
asked that and i i think i would have
picked up a lot more vibe i will tell
you this
there's two coaches there that would
have them tomorrow one is byron leftwich
who wish he had more than eight months
with him the other one is clyde
christensen his quarterback coach both
those guys
i think would be fine with jamison
and you know right now jameis is looking
for her work right so i i mean you know
i know his dad is getting talked to
people and said he'd be fine coming back
to tampa i don't think bruce aaron's is
fine with it i just you know um been
there done that uh
there was a time when there were seven
and seven his one year here under bruce
and i thought he was going to make it he
fought through for like 460 something
two games in a row
uh and then they played houston who they
absolutely dominated on defense and then
they played atlanta and he threw both
goat games away and i i saw on bruce's
face that day that he had he had reached
his limit with jameis winston and i i
think it'd be really hard you know i i
think
and he may be like he may be better than
these other guys we're talking about but
at the end of the day
if if he goes out there week one week
two throws a pick six throws a couple
interceptions what's everybody writing
what's everybody saying
would he even have a chance here with
the fan base i i
i just don't think that uh that they
would go that direction well then the
the alternative of blayne gabbert though
and is where i think you know the
blowback comes with is just like
all right like what are the what are the
chances he could turn into brad johnson
right like what are the what are the
chances of everything that you just said
about well garoppolo if you run it 40
times why not um but they don't do that
and jameis you know uh bruce has been
there done that i mean
gabbard
maybe
the issue is is he hasn't played in so
long and before that he wasn't
any um championship caliber quality and
fans oh and tampa only know him as the
guy who's brady's tequila sunrise
partner to get him home you know i mean
so
that you know what i'm saying like how
is gabbard an upgrade over anything that
you just kind of shot down knowing the
way that the bucks have shot him down i
totally get it i totally get it but is
is he that much
is he that much different right is he
that much worse and that's the
evaluation that bruce and those guys
have to make um blaine gabbert you know
he's had a history the record is
terrible um you know he he was drafted
by not a good jacksonville team he had
you know some like seven or eight
coordinators in that many years
um when he did go to arizona a long time
ago when bruce was there
he won a couple games over wherever
teams were winning records and he beat
the colts he uh believe he beat somebody
else that was decent
and um
and and since he's been here
he's 32 years old uh he keeps himself in
amazing shape he's got the size the
speed he's got a cannon for an arm when
he has had to play in mop up duty um he
lit it up fine now understand who he's
playing with you know this would be the
best team he's ever played with in terms
of weapons assuming they franchise or
re-sign godwin they got mike evans
we don't think gronk is coming back
they're probably going to draft the wide
receiver and they got some holes to fill
for sure both on the offensive line and
figure out what they're going to do at
running back but it's still
a pretty good football team in a system
that he's been in now for a number of
years i'm just telling you what bruce
says right this is bruce's take on him
is that he thinks he's a hell of a lot
better than everybody else thinks he is
and maybe bruce is dead wrong
um but
he believes that you know
when you look at the field right the
guys that are available or what you have
to give up to get certain people or what
the owners can stomach
etc
um maybe you're better off
letting him compete letting kyle trask
who they like going to training camp and
compete and you know worst case scenario
somewhere down the road kyle trask is
your future quarterback it's just it's
not a good year for the draft we know
that they're not going to draft a guy
they're picking 27 so how attractive is
that pick to another team
i'm sure you could package two or three
years worth of first rounders and hope
i'm not saying it's over i'm just saying
that i think blaine will be on this team
and i think crap trafficking that's
where they're starting from if they can
add somebody else great you know does
baker mayfield fall out of the pile
somewhere along the line i mean does you
know that no one's
you know there's just not a lot of
quarterbacks it's not like the year that
tom came out where he was a free agent
he could pick it and you had phillip
rivers and you know at that time
bridgewater was 5-0 with new orleans and
you know there were guys that they liked
including jamis at that time
and now i think it's changed and you're
talking about a different set of
circumstances which by the way how many
teams need a quarterback
show of hands here there's about 12 of
them
it could be more even um it could be
even more rick stroud tampa bay times
here on the rich eisen show so we spent
the last few minutes throwing out names
that might not be blaine gabert as the
starting quarterback of the tampa bay
buccaneers come week one of 2022 here's
another one here's one last one for you
tom brady what about that one what about
that one rick
well if they you know if they had blaine
and they had kyle and some you know
second tier guy was here and we got to
august or september even or you know
right at the start of the season and tom
said he wants to play
they're going to absolutely own his
rights um sometime after june 1st
they're going to put him on the reserve
retired list
he's going to count 8 million against
the cap this year and 24 million against
the cap in 2023
and if he wants to play
they believe this is them talking now
they believe he would play here
because
at 45 does he really want to go to
another team learn a new offense new
players all of that or
they know or he knows that the bucks
will do everything they can mortgage
more future bring in any player they
want he wants and try to make another
run at it so i'm not saying they're
keeping you know the seat open they have
to proceed as if he's retired and i and
i sort of believe that he is
um but it's always you know
i think it's going to be a possibility
until it's not right until they were to
just you know make some bold move
whether that was with watson because the
owners were satisfied his problems are
behind him they give up a ton of draft
capital for future years if there's a
guy in here that they've spent
you know a lot of money or indoor picks
on
then you know tom's probably out of the
picture and to be honest if brady went
to them and there's a theory out there
about this i don't know if it's true but
if brady went to them
and said listen i want to play for this
team not not the bucks but another team
i think they would be so
grateful for what he gave them for two
years
that the glazer family would not hold
him up they would not say hey it's here
or nowhere but
um
you know i mean i watched rich mckay
walk out of here as a gm one day he was
the gm of the bucks they let him go to
atlanta for god's sakes and a week later
they were he was the gm of the falcons
playing in raymond james and again it
was gratitude for all he had done for
them getting the stadium all that stuff
so
i just know the glazers i don't think
they would hold tom up and we all
suspect that that would be san francisco
that would be the place that you know he
might want to have one last shot at it
uh his hometown team but
they don't believe that they believe
that if tom were to change his mind
that he would play here and what about
the concept of gear grinding that was
happening over the last year um right
and i i know uh aryans and you had
very strident quotes from him shooting
down that
that he was um gumming up the game plans
that brady was working on with leftwitch
at the last moment or red penciling red
marking or something like that i mean
what do you what do you make of uh
whatever was going on behind the scenes
that you may be aware of that could
discount brady coming back what do you
think of that one
well i mean the literal you know
redlining didn't happen um
for sure and part of that
narrative was that you know
bruce was working on his achilles in the
morning and bruce doesn't work on his
achilles in the morning so you know
this this the way this has worked since
since bruce got here is that byron
leftwich runs the offense he does all of
it he's in at 3 30 4 o'clock in the
morning
bruce was never going to do scripts
bruce was never going to do game
planning in the sense that you put
together the plan for the entire week
etc now he gets the game plan he will
look at it he will tweak it he will add
to it but he doesn't take things away
generally and as brady was here we
remember they were seven and five it
didn't look like the bucks offense they
had a big you know
sort of meeting then
uh and and ba was involved more and they
did some things you know with with tom
to make it more his offense which is
what we saw this past season
brady does the game planning as much as
leftwich does it with him and so
i i just
i don't you know i don't think that's
true
um and bruce was emphatic about that
part of it what what is possible though
like anybody that has a boss like you
don't always get along with them all the
time right i mean
and there were things that happened last
year that i'm sure upset brady i'm sure
he didn't like
the result at least of having antonio
brown not on this roster
you know he needed another receiver
godwin got hurt
um the first game that brown could have
come back after the
fake vaxcard suspension was new orleans
they lost nine to nothing they were down
six to nothing until the last minute or
so
and
within a span of ten minutes they lost
three of their top players and antonio
brown been around for that that would
have been great um that you know and but
that was a suspension situation and then
um you know he
does come back he lights it up one game
uh 10 catches 110 yards gets carolina
the next week he's mad at tom he's mad
at everybody at halftime about not
getting the ball enough
and then we saw what happened with the
you know the shirt off and the whole
thing with the jets
and it was messy and the biggest thing
is it took away a weapon you know it it
hurt them it hurt tom um and it was it
was just you know there were things like
that that i'm sure
he wasn't pleased with but why would
that be the fault of the bucks at all
like why would brady not be happy it's
not it's it's antonio brown's um
responsibility you know i mean whatever
was going on with his ankle and you know
in the last couple weeks i mean if
brady's upset at anything about what
happened with brown all he's going to do
is look to the gram or the tweet or
whatever that that bra that brown put
out this week about the mri proving that
that uh he was forced out on the field
and then he did he deleted it because it
was re people pointed out it was a year
old what he popped up about his mri so
why would brady be upset about anything
of the way that the brown situation was
handled i don't know that he was other
than that brown was fired right like
he's fired and fired immediately like
the first thing bruce said after the
game is he's out of here and i don't
know what other option bruce had refused
to
this is all speculation right i don't
know what he would be unhappy about the
coaches i'm telling you the coaches that
work with him every day work with brady
every day never heard him come in and
you know say derogatory things about ba
or i can't stand it that just never
happens so that i you know like i said
do you like everything people do could
they have been you know maybe more
attention to detail in practice for the
walkthroughs
could if anything rich um
he probably wanted more right he always
wanted more maybe he wanted him to sign
odell beckham jr uh who was a free agent
at the time and ba said uh a b o obj too
many initials maybe he would have liked
to see them you know trade away a two
and a three for von miller who hit him
nine times in that divisional playoff
game right um
you know tom has made mention that the
rams really went for it and that's what
the bucks did a year ago the bucks just
had so many injuries and if not for some
bad play calling and some bad execution
at the end against the rams they they
win that game in overtime and we're
talking about another one of the
greatest comebacks in playoff history
with tom brady so
um you know it's it's hard to
i don't know where this gets started i
guess it's people around me i mean i
don't but the folks that i know that are
around brady and the folks that are
around the box think that this is like
kind of a false narrative that
he has any bad
mojo or vibes about playing in tampa
it's true the team's going to be
different
but they would figure out the cap
situation they would bring as many guys
back as they could they draft whoever
get whoever
and i think tom knows that so
you know can we just accept that the
guy's gonna retire after 22 seasons i
think that's people want to blame you
know blame somebody for that and really
it's tom's choice
for sure and i hope everything is well
between him and the bucks just for the
mere fact that if there is a movie
called 80 for brady we got to get we got
to get tom moore in there in some sort
of a cameo don't you think
don't think yeah
we thought tom was retired and it turns
out he's just working nine to five with
lilly thompson ladies and gentlemen
sally field and rita moreno right i mean
yeah
well done if his movie career is going
anywhere does he have to play someone
besides himself is that really acting
well i think i think it i think you know
um it 100 percent uh means that he's got
the bug let's see let's see if he
expands the brand a little bit you know
what i mean like i wanted to be the next
james bond or something i don't know
let's see what he can do
tom wick i don't know you know what i'm
saying like tom wick you know what i
mean i don't i'm just throwing it out
there we're thinking oh
we've had 80 for brady men in the arena
and what's next man in the mirror i mean
like you know the guy
um he's gotta be he's gotta play someone
else i think he's gotta it's maybe he's
gotta branch out just a little bit
because the next guy that comes to him
with hey i got a great idea
i know we're gonna do a story yeah about
you and you're you're gonna play
yourself as a quarterback you know what
which super bowl would you like to
to emulate
super bowl 57 with the 49ers how does
that sound oh man there we go
well that'll wrap it up thanks for the
call rick appreciate it as always all
right buddy you go there you go at nfl
stroud follow him i do always love our
chats with you i love it super bowl 57
starring tom brady as the 49ers starting
quarterback
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here